and i am
iron man
Hey dad. Morgan, wow.
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
new avengers and game deleted scene for iron man
in the soul world of the soul stone so i'll
explain what's going on here it's the anniversary
of avengers end game it came out two years ago
that's how long it's been so the russos were
releasing a bunch more deleted scenes and really
cool stuff from behind the scenes so we'll break
it all down there's a whole bunch of easter
eggs here i'll also talk about the future of
the iron man character in marvel phase four like
the iron man armor war series that's going to be
happening next year so if you're brand new to the
channel i'll be doing videos for all the marvel
disney plus episodes be sure to subscribe to get
everything loki is going to be the next big series
to premiere pretty soon but re-watching this
scene most of you can probably tell what's meant
to be happening in this moment even though the way
you're watching it through the monitors is kind of
hard to tell the scene itself was meant to happen
right after iron man snaps the nano infinity
gauntlet being a parallel for the thanos scene
of him going into the soul world after the first
time he snapped the infinity gauntlet in avengers
infinity war the russo brothers and the writers
called it the way station when they were filming
this scene like a cosmic way station because of
the way the soul world works inside the soul stone
i will explain how the soul stone and the soul
world works in the mcu in a second because it does
get pretty crazy with the way they explain some
of the twists in this scene but what you're seeing
here is the version of the deleted scene where his
fingers are still in the process of snapping when
he enters the soul world but because what you see
in the soul world is only meant to be a cosmic
representation of people's souls their life force
their essence it kind of acts like a holodeck
situation where your own mind is sort of conjuring
the stuff that you see in here so that's the
reason why he's not wearing his armor in here
he just thinks of himself this way normally so
he's wearing the clothes that he was wearing
before he activated his armor earlier in the movie
and what he's seeing in here is a combination of
memories of the past mixed with the essence of a
future version of his daughter morgan stark played
by catherine langford i will explain the time
travel aspect to this too like why she appears
as the older teenage version of herself instead of
the little girl version from present day it's the
same reason why thanos sees the younger version of
gamora instead of the one from present day when he
entered the soul world but her essence the after
image of her life force tells iron man that his
gambit worked his rolling of the dice that one
chance in 14 million doctor strange told him about
without saying so many words the way they justify
that he said he couldn't tell him exactly because
he was worried that iron man would then try to
find a way out of it because that's what he does
but you could kind of tell the way they played
that scene the looks on their faces iron man
totally understood what doctor strange meant when
he held that finger up like okay i have to snap
the infinity gauntlet or the whole universe dies
there's a much longer version of this scene on
my channel that i posted a long time ago so i'll
post a link for that down in the description if
you haven't seen that yet but there is some very
potato quality looking footage of them talking
to each other sharing this moment in teenage
morgan stark's dialogue is basically that she
mom referencing pepper potts everyone is okay in
the future it all worked out just fine basically
telling him he can rest easy it all worked
the whole reason the russos and the writers
said that they filmed this scene was to give iron
man a moment after he took that chance snapping
the gauntlet to let him know that it worked
because in reality he actually died right after
this happened and you'd have no way of knowing
if your own sacrifice like that had paid off
unless someone literally time traveled back from
the future to tell you that it worked like oh
i'm from 10 years from now it totally worked
we're all good so here's how they explain the
time travel aspect of this scene because time
travel is a big trope in the mcu now like the
loki series that's coming up this summer will
essentially be a time travel multiverse series
with him hopping around in the timeline but also
traveling to alternate timelines within the mcu
the way they explain those alternate timelines is
they function like fully alternate realities like
alternate universes but this version of teenage
morgan stark that iron man is talking to here
isn't actually the real morgan stark traveling
back into the past to meet him in the soul world
some of you have probably figured this out in
the two years since avengers end game came out
but what's actually happening here is that the
soul world inside the soul stone is a place that
exists outside of normal space time like a pocket
dimension that exists outside of space-time kind
of like the speed force so when you're inside the
soul world you experience the past the present and
the future all at the same time so that's why iron
man is meeting the older version of his daughter
but they're inside the campsite with the tent
there from earlier in the movie that the younger
version of morgan stark had in the teenage
version of morgan stark that's talking to him
here catherine langford is just meant to be the
after image the life force the essence of the real
morgan stark in this after image of her just
retained all of her memories from the future
so this is why the soul stone is one of the most
dangerous or most powerful infinity stones because
it has this connection to all the souls the
life force of every living thing in the universe
that's sort of the critical part of the infinity
gauntlet snap that thanos makes is that he's able
to erase half of all life because the soul stone
connects the rest of the infinity stones in him
to all life in the universe so the real morgan
stark never needs to actually physically touch
the soul stone or go inside the soul world
herself in order for it to retain a copy of her
that's also how they explain the young version of
gamora inside the soul world as well like it just
retains a connection to her soul and thanos sees
her as a young version of herself because he's
the person that's conjuring a lot of the imagery
around here but right after this scene you have
the scene of spider-man pepper potts roadie coming
to say goodbye to iron man as he dies and then the
other deleted scene of everyone taking the knee
as the young gamora walks off talking more about
gamora just leaves taking off the planet the
funny thing about this scene too is everyone
was like man gamora's cold she's not going to pay
any reference to iron man or honor him in any way
you have to remember that the younger version
of gamora that traveled into the future the
gamora from 2014 never met iron man so she had no
connection to him didn't have any idea who he was
she didn't even have the connection to peter quilt
that's why she kicked him in the nuts when he went
in for the kiss earlier they'll get into that
version of gamora when we get to guardians of the
galaxy vol 3. i don't think that she's supposed
to cameo during thor 4 love and thunder with the
other guardians because i think the idea is that
they haven't gone out and found her and brought
her back into the fold yet but the whole reason
why they got rid of this iron man soul world scene
is because it's kind of a little cringy but also
because way too many people in the test audiences
were confused about who catherine langford was
playing they didn't immediately realize that
she was supposed to be the older version of morgan
stark everyone just got hung up on them not doing
the scene with the little girl version of morgan
stark like why wouldn't he see the little girl
version of his daughter when he went in here so
we just over complicated the ending of the movie
which had already gone on for about a half hour
the whole big third act battle here is about a
half hour long and it wound up overshadowing his
actual death scene which you wanted to have this
real weight to it so as fun as it is to watch this
scene i do love watching all these deleted scenes
i think they made the right call in removing
it and katherine langford separately did say
she'd love to come back in more marvel movies or
disney plus series as an older version of morgan
stark but the only way they could really make it
work is to do it as a time travel story because
her version of the character is like 12 15 years
older than the little girl version of morgan stark
in present day 2023 so i think right off the bat
best option for something like that would be a
potential future young avengers series when they
get around to making that and here's where we get
to the whole iron man iron heart armor wars of
it all because before marvel had announced the
official iron heart disney plus series there's
been some talk about that today as well i would
have actually said they could just turn morgan
stark into their iron heart in the mcu and just
make her more like a version of iron lad from the
comics for more young avengers connections because
in the comics iron lad is a time travel character
but he's basically a little kid version of king of
the conqueror just pretending to be someone else
earlier in the movie they had that whole scene
with morgan stark wearing pepper potts iron man
armor and it seemed like good setup for them to
pay off in a future series where an adult version
of her character shows up wearing a full suit of
armor but what marvel is actually doing now with
the iron man legacy the iron man character is
basically the armor war series and riri williams
iron heart series couple minor changes from the
comic book versions of those stories but the iron
heart series is supposed to come before armor wars
although i'm expecting rhodey war machine to show
up during ironheart and for her to cross over
unto armor wars like ironheart will probably
feed directly into armor wars just because
those two characters share so much of a connection
to iron man's legacy in his lore they have already
cast the riri williams character but her episodes
probably won't release until next summer 2022
and be a slightly different version of her comic
book origin story with less actual robert downey
jr on screen than what you saw from the comic book
version of that story so in that story iron man
almost died went into this deep coma so he was
effectively dead even though he wasn't actually
dead but he'd backed up his consciousness to his
computer systems as an artificial intelligence
so he became like a jarvis version of tony stark
running around the mcu hopping from computer to
computer he was able to mentor riri williams until
she eventually took the iron heart name and then
started working on her own with other young
avengers heroes in the marvel universe like
the champions and the actual young avengers team
so pretty easy prediction to make that eventually
mcu riri williams will probably show up in a
young avengers roster when they get around to
making that project along with older versions of
scarlet witch's children billy and tommy wicken
and speed from the comics miss marvel kamala khan
kate bishop hawkeye elijah bradley patriot who
we just saw on falcon and winter soldier i know
that a lot of people that are trying to come up
with theories about how he gets the super soldier
serum like maybe he gets a blood transfusion from
his grandfather isaiah bradley you also have
the cassie lang stature that we'll see during
ant-man 3 and maybe a couple other new characters
they'll introduce in the disney plus series it's
going to be a long time before we see any young
avengers project but if you remember how they
treated old man cap during the falcon and winter
soldier episodes that's probably how they'll
treat robert downey jr's iron man during iron
heart in the armor war series like they did have
that scene right at the beginning of falcon and
winter soldier episode 1 where you hear old man
cap's speech to falcon from endgame where he was
giving him the shield but that's about as close to
a cameo scene as we got like he didn't actually
appear on screen they just kept making funny
references to him secretly being on the moon like
i thought the captain america was on the moon so i
would recommend you have similar expectations for
robert downey jr in these new marvel disney plus
series like they include some playback of him from
previous movies and dialogue that he spoke using
that in different contexts in new scenes maybe
another holographic recording like the i love
you 3000 recording from endgame the past couple of
years robert downey jr has been back and forth on
whether or not he's actually coming back like he
said it would be interesting and you know he might
think about it at some point in the future never
say never but right now i don't know necessarily
that he's actually booked to actually come back
anytime soon there are all kinds of rumors about
him showing up on different series using a couple
twisty ways to explain it but i'll talk about that
if it actually winds up happening but everyone
let me know in the comments how do you want them
to use the iron man character and his legacy going
forward in the mcu just gotta hold out for secret
wars when they can pull in an alternate universe
version of tony stark that's still alive maybe
we'll get some easter eggs for that during doctor
strange 2 multiverse of madness like alternate
universe version of iron man while you wait for
everything everyone click here for that brand new
captain america 4 marvel movie announcement and
click here for my full falcon and winter soldier
episode 6 video thank you so much for watching on
your left everyone and i'll see you guys tonight!